geez gordo maybe pass on the 1500
glass of wine i wonder how many of those
speaking engagements he'd have to do
to buy a bottle like that have to say i
didn't see that move
coming and yeah that's a setup for his
time on the moon to be sure
hey guys pete here this is my for all
mankind
season 2 episode 6 breakdown it's titled
best laid plans
and as we move into the back half of the
season things are starting to come into
focus
we'll get into what those plans are
shaping up to be but first
let me give a quick spoiler warning if
you haven't watched episode 6 yet then
this will
absolutely spoil it for you hit the
subscribe button go watch it and then
come back
and with that out of the way let's jump
into it plot wise i really enjoyed the
soviet delegation coming to the us
i think it's been a thing sort of
hanging over this series
that there was never any perspective on
what was going on with the soviets
we only saw things from one perspective
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
because it does add to the tension of
all the interactions that they have with
each other
but in an alternate history situation
where we're expecting things to turn out
a different way
i think it does become necessary for us
to see their side of the story
and we've got these two parallel things
going on with them we have an escalation
of the cold war
we have the militarization of the moon
and the space program
in general but then we also have this
apollo soyuz thing
which on the surface is there to foster
goodwill
but as we see in this episode nobody
really
wants it to happen we get the pentagon's
perspective
they would be more than happy for things
to fall through as long as they're not
the ones with egg on their face
we can see that the official position of
the soviets is to not give an inch
and then we got danny in there she's
just happy to be in the room
she's just trying to make the most out
of her command
and then somewhat surprisingly thomas
paine
is really behind the idea for history's
sake which i guess somebody has to be
because it looks like this thing needs
to happen but both sides are more
interested in not giving anything away
not showing any weakness not making it
easy for the other side
and it looks like payne's our guy or at
least he's our guy to delegate things to
margot
which i will come back to i'll tell you
what though this is the second time they
showed us
a nicer side of pain showed that he
really cared about his job
that he wasn't just the politician
wasn't just the ear of the president
and i gotta say that puts up some red
flags i have to imagine that we're going
to see him lose his job
one way or the other that was one of the
big takeaways i had from this
and one of the other things that it made
me think about was as we see ellen
getting
closer to moving away from her position
and her working with him so closely i
hope there's not some kind of scandal or
something else that's going to come out
of that situation
either way to me it feels like they're
definitely setting something up with
thomas payne
it could be as simple as he gets pushed
out of the position in an election
but there's tension at the top around
this handshake in space
and that means margot has to figure out
a way to make it work
and that was mostly enjoyable to watch
we see that there's some chemistry going
on i think between her and sergey
they're both in a tough situation but
figure out a way to work together
elena gets caught up in that as well and
it seems like there might be an issue
with her supervisor bill who's a
familiar face that we've seen
throughout the entire run but in the end
they get the design to work
they present it everyone's happy sergey
acts like he wasn't involved in the
process
and then he breaks the stalemate with
the transmission codes by telling what
theirs is
first and pretty much everything's back
on track by the end of the episode
we get some good character moments as
danny and her crew member
hang out with the cosmonauts things
start off rough obviously
they go for burgers and you think maybe
that's gonna open the door
but there's still kind of a lot of
posturing going on
and then we see a slight break whenever
the soyuz commander
talks about the astronaut dog leica what
was interesting about that to me was
that they were
not really in agreement nobody changed
anybody else's mind really
but they still managed to connect on a
human level and i would guess that they
have a higher respect for each other
which is probably going to be necessary
as a result
danny's story ends with what almost felt
like a stinger at the very end of the
episode
when she arrives in russia with her
crewmate and they get a much
different reception we'll have to see
what's up with that in the next episode
though
because they never get past the
introduction so i opened up with gordo
and yep that's his plan he wants to go
back to the moon
and try to get tracy back i thought that
it was pretty interesting that we had
never seen
her husband on camera until this episode
and i guess he turns out to be what we
were expecting
he's the kind of guy who has bottles of
wine that thomas jefferson used to own
he's awfully confident and doesn't seem
too worried about gordo's plans
which could turn out bad for gordo let's
be honest
however it seems like he's been on this
path to overcome what happened the last
time so i'm not really sure how him
going back to the moon and then striking
out with tracy would really fit into
that
unless of course he is just heading for
a meltdown and always has been this
season we'll have to wait and see
either way it was a fun twist you kind
of saw it come to his mind
as he was overhearing his son talking to
tracy
and he went outside and sort of looked
up at the moon but i was still
pretty surprised to hear it come out of
his mouth tracy on the other hand
is starting to bond with the marines it
looks like and i guess that makes sense
she wasn't really fitting in with the
other astronauts because of her
celebrity status
and it looks like her skills at piloting
the lsam might come in handy
she's supposed to be training one of the
marines but he doesn't look like he's
very good at it yet
and that makes you wonder if she's not
going to be involved in whatever it is
they do
the only other thing that happened up
there was we do hear her talking with
deke again
she's kind of talking about she wants
something that lasts nothing on earth
lasts
almost sounds like she might be missing
gordo but really
is that where we're going i'm not sure
it seemed like they were going out of
their way to show that she was happy
with her new life then she goes to the
moon
we find out she's not that happy at
least not in that environment
and now her ex-husband who she hasn't
seemed all that interested in
lately is coming to try to win her over
elsewhere we do get a little bit of pam
and ellen we could see that ellen is all
in on this idea of getting back together
and not unsurprisingly pam doesn't trust
her
she doesn't want to throw everything
that she has right now away again
just to watch ellen not be able to pull
the trigger if you will
make a real commitment to the
relationship we see her go and talk to
larry
afterward and of course he's worried
about her coming out he doesn't really
want a divorce he likes the life they
have together
and you kind of feel a little bit bad
for him and it's one of those situations
that kind of hit because
neither one of them did anything wrong
here and his reasons for not wanting
things to end
isn't entirely selfish i think we still
have to imagine that if ellen is gonna
try to make this
a real relationship go public with it
then she's gonna experience a backlash
and will probably have to quit nasa
having said that you can still easily
understand her position
and understand why she might go that
direction she's in love that's all there
is to it really
beyond that we get a little bit of ed
and karen we see them watching a sea
dragon launch on the tv
and kelly's trying to write her letter
for the naval academy
and they get into this conversation
about why they
adopted her so it goes back to a real
thing that exists in our timeline and
that's
operation baby lift i'm not sure where
they're going bringing this up
at this point i think we'll see more
about that in the next episode
i think the big takeaway here for me was
that we get a little bit more insight
into how hard things were for them after
shane died
we find out that they were separated at
a time and that kelly played a key role
in them coming back together after they
adopted her
i'm not sure what's going on here i did
find it a little bit relieving that we
didn't see
any new interactions between danny and
karen
i was glad that we kind of didn't have
to go there we did see edit work we saw
him doing
a flight simulation with his pathfinder
crew
he looks like he's on top of his game as
far as that's concerned
his crew seems impressed things seem to
be moving along well
there and we'll just have to wait and
see what's going on at home
and how things develop ed and karen have
always come across as the kind of couple
that stay together no matter what
they have their problems as individuals
and as a couple
and they've dealt with their share of
tragedy most of that
has appeared to keep them together
though so it's hard to put together
something that i'd like to see happen
with them kelly's nearly an adult now
which means she'll be developing as an
independent character
who has her own arc in future seasons i
don't know i kind of like things as they
are there
ed had his moment earlier in the season
they were there for each other
karen's got the business now she seems
in her element there
maybe they don't need to be in the
center of things this season
i definitely like this episode better
than the last one
it feels like it's gaining some momentum
now always enjoy some focus on margot
and they put her in an interesting
position even brought some on-screen
chemistry into the mix you have to
imagine that her working with sergey
and then danny bonding with the soyuz
commander will be important later
because let's face it conflict is coming
not sure what to expect with gordo and
tracy or even when i want to come out of
that development to be honest
i guess hopefully it's just not extreme
to the point that they come back
together only for one of them to get
killed off right
i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you think about
where we are
and where we might be going probably not
a great sign that the marines completely
missed the target when they were trying
out their new guns so let me know what
you think about that
and anything else that's on your mind
about this season so far
because we are making our way towards
the end please like this video if you
enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon